yo i forgot to tell y'all there was a
throuple
at a throuple at uh my show in tampa
with a throttle
that's that's a three-person love
triangle
so your personal like they're they're in
a relationship
yeah like a couple we call it though
yeah
i would just call that an open
relationship no
they're all they all like each other
there's one dude two chicks
yes hell yeah have you ever seen it the
other way oh yeah
two dudes one chick yes i think that's a
pansexual right no
oh yeah you've seen it yeah i have a
friend who does that
really yeah he shouldn't be tweeting
they're all in a relationship yeah they
live together like
and have kids oh my god like i like you
i like you i like you
yeah man figure it out two dudes one
girl yep
i've never seen it though good for her
but uh but this great for her
this couple that you saw were they
attractive
i was on stage and i i saw the
i saw the three sitting there thorpe
yeah i saw the throw pull sitting there
and the dude uh uh all of a sudden like
the two girls
just like re reach across the the table
and just start making out hardcore
while like while i'm in the middle of my
session so they were like [ __ ] this show
let's be real but they were they came up
to me they were so nice they were
really really nice you know how they
actually really liked it yeah so they
were making out there in the middle of
the show
you know i and i didn't want to call it
during your main punchline
i was about to say i was just kind of
talking so so they were
making out and you're like because
because like the dude was in the did you
look at the guy and the guy went like
this
no no they actually weren't even like
that it wasn't even like like oh this is
our
sexual thing that we do they actually
genuinely
were just altering a couple yeah it's
not gonna work out but sure how do you
know that
name one person that's worked out for do
you real david oh you ready
ray davis who's d-ray davis i know d-ray
but he he has two girlfriends yes and
they live together
there's a whole thing they they live
together happy relationships sister
wives
happy sister wives they do that all the
time i'll tell you right now but do the
girls like each other
i'll tell you i'll tell you right now
that's what i'm saying like yeah sure no
sure
yep sure there's a thing yep sure here's
the thing
it's a nightmare at home guarantee it
how you figured it out i wonder what the
you know what because you know what i
had a hurry that's my question
i wonder what like yeah what if you know
two of them are arguing
you know what i mean what's the third
one doing while they're arguing trying
jumping aside trying to change
the middle man yeah that nightmare i had
a buddy who did an open relationship
forever well documented i'll be marcus
nightmare he was so stressed out all the
time
think about it when you you think about
the chicken how'd you deal with you're
you're trying to
[ __ ] you're trying to you're trying
to love it's
like think about that managing all those
personalities
no they probably all you know this
couple i'm telling you this is going to
oh
this come from a dude who just got a
girlfriend for the first time
okay wow
you know how it like think about
thinking about you have your queen now i
think if you have that 83 year old
ruling out you got that 86 68 and that's
[ __ ]
think if you had all those girls and you
have to manage those personalities all
the time well
you're basically the producer of [ __ ]
real love and hip-hop you know what i'm
saying
like you're dealing with drama all but
how do you know if it's drama because
they didn't seem dramatic when i was
they were all pretty like oh you're
talking about your comedy show on
saturday night yeah dude
yeah they're out friday friday that
ain't real that's a good day
that's not real no it doesn't work out i
wonder
my boy i'll be marcus i mean he'll come
on and talk about like he was like dude
i
it was like i was doing his for a minute
a long time
sure i'm telling you man at the end of
the day it's a when they lay their head
down
it's a nightmare oh i couldn't i i mix
then what happens when one wants kids
then what you're gonna do you give both
of them kids
i know i don't think i could [ __ ]
ever do it man well that's a lot because
i
like now i hope it works out and good
for him that would be a great idea
pimp's surviving pimps man no are you
serious
pimps they have the manuals managed six
seven eight girls and they seem
happy yeah dude yeah do they seem happy
no they always gotta slap [ __ ] up and
they gotta
always trying to make money because yeah
if they listen i saw we're not talking
about
pens we're talking about a strictly a
relationship yeah my god my friend
my my dude like back in the hood one of
my homies he's a pimp and he lived with
his girls
and uh all of them they used to beat him
so stressed out
he's gotta be well yeah because they
yeah you got to be and that's
that's a lot that's too many [ __ ]
people bro and then you're dealing with
hookers not mentally stable to
start and then you're you're constantly
and then here's the other thing
you're basically an owner of a [ __ ]
nba team because they get older
you can't you got to get new blood in
there you feel me look at him
yeah yeah
i saw i saw your face you got to recruit
all the time
i'm not a pimp i don't know but you
gotta find those girls who are open for
that business
you remember it was a porn star uh
marcus uh uh
oh no brian pumper uh
yo he used to be on the track no
oh hell yeah what nah don't he had the
fake jury he had all that
he goes to the gym and recruit women oh
you go on a train or he'll be on like
the city bus the city bus
porno no to recruit women to recruit
women to do porn yeah that's what i'm
saying to do
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and they
used to make fun of her
like like my cousin got approached by
him oh i was watching this documentary
there's this guy
who drives a taxi and he ends up [ __ ]
the girls in the taxi they talk
about fake tax yeah i know i'm off the
documentary i mean i'm in them streets
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song